what happened to your party that folks
like me don't even consider it anymore
they never put somebody up there who I
would even consider voting for the party
he's taken a sharp turn to the right and
for example I am a Republican of course
and principally because of my background
my feelings about foreign policy and
defense spending and things like that
but I'm very moderate with respect to
social issues and I found increasingly
over the last 10 or 15 years the party's
moved further away from somebody like me
and my lecturing to the party and I've
talked to senior officials the party of
that if we're really going to be a
successful party particularly in
presidential elections you have got to
start appealing to more than the base
and you definitely have to start
appealing to minorities because the
minorities are going to be the majority
in about 20 years
hello-hello hispanics asian-americans an
african-american is going to be the
majority of Americans so my Republican
colleagues have got to understand this
and I've got to appreciate the views of
the far-right but it can't be the only
view that is taken into account within
the party or else they're going to
suddenly run into a brick wall and have
difficulties and it also contributes to
the lack of credibility that exists
between the two parties and the way in
which Congress has gotten itself o
gridlocked because they can't find ways
to look across argue their position and
then find compromise that's the way our
founding fathers did it my gosh in 1789
these guys argued stuck in a room no
television
stuck in a room but they came out with
compromises to include a horrible one
three-fifths of rehearsing like me not
having any rights whatsoever but they
had to do that in order to create a
constitution and we had to fight with
that till today